und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel berichte
und christian sievers guten abend hinein wie
abhängig wir sind von dauernden facebook updates
der schönen bilder welt bei instagram und dem
kling der whatsapp mitteilungen das lässt sich
gerade gut im selbstversuch testen alle diese
dienste die alle zum facebook imperium gehören
sind seit heute nachmittag weitgehend vom netz
gestört doch es gibt ein problem steht da jetzt
und das gilt auch für facebook selbst nur was
geklickt und geleitet wird findet statt in den
sogenannten sozialen medien für ein netzwerk wie
facebook das unfassbar viel geld damit verdient
lautet deshalb die entscheidende frage wie bringt
man die leute dazu möglichst viel zu klicken
und zu leiten die antwort am einfachsten durch
wut hass und spaltung so sagt das eine die es
wissen müsste francis horgen hat selbst bei
facebook gearbeitet in der abteilung die gegend
falschinformationen vorgehen soll und sie geht
jetzt an die öffentlichkeit im gepäck eigene
studien des internetgiganten zehntausende seiten
interner dokumente die ihren ex-arbeitgeber enorm
in schwierigkeiten bringen könnten ich habe immer
wieder beobachtet dass es interessenkonflikte gab
bei der frage was ist gut für die öffentlichkeit
und was ist gut für facebook und facebook hat
sich immer wieder für die eigenen interessen
entschieden zum beispiel mehr geld zu verdienen
die heutige version von facebook heißt unsere
gesellschaft auseinander und führt zu ethnischer
gewalt auf der ganzen welt das sind vorwürfe die
mächtig wirbel machen in den usa die ex managerin
wird morgen im parlament aussagen sie treffen den
internetgiganten in einer zeit in der dessen
praktiken auch der politik zunehmend unheimlich
werden konnten berichtet ein visionär der die welt
mit technologie beflügelt so inszeniert sich mark
zuckerberg ein image dass kratzer bekommen hat
wer ist der chef eines unglaublich mächtigen
unternehmens mit drei milliarden rosa doch
eher handelt so als ob er das fahrwerk seines
flugzeuges erst baut wenn es schon in der luft ist
facebook riskiere die sicherheit seiner user und
gefährde die demokratie die reporterinnen cäcilia
king und schira frenkel werfen in ihrem buch an
ugly truth eine hässliche wahrheit mark zuckerberg
und co geschäftsführerin sheryl sandberg einen
skrupellosen expansionskurs vor der artikel
stammt von einer führungskraft er sprach von
einer hässlichen wahrheit um die realität bei
facebook zu beschreiben wie die führungsriege
wiederholt ähnliche entscheidungen trifft und
fehler in ländern wie myanmar oder anderswo
begeht die dazu führen dass menschen getötet
werden 2017 startete das militär im januar eine
desinformationskampagne gegen die muslimische
rohingya minderheit facebooks algorithmus hätte
hass verbreitet die gewalt eskalierte 25.000
menschen starben hunderttausende flohen die
konzernzentrale in kalifornien habe warnungen von
menschenrechts-organisationen ignoriert bis 2018
gab es nur fünf sie sprechen die mitarbeiter innen
für einen markt von 18 millionen usern facebook
facebook braucht die beteiligung seiner user um zu
wachsen sieht algorithmus zielt darauf ab user zu
binden spielt aufsehen erregen dass nach oben das
bedeutet dass er inhalte priorisiert die emotionen
erzeugen egal ob mode traurigkeit light oder
empörung oftmals dinge die einen am meisten in die
irre führen oder das informieren ein algorithmus
der auch im vorfeld der attacke auf das kapitol
die zugriffe auf facebook wachsen hieß so habe
dieser trump verloren gruppen empfohlen in denen
sich gewaltbereite demonstranten organisierten die
autorinnen kommen zu einem erstaunlichen schluss
facebook habe bereits vor dem 6 januar gewusst was
geplant war sie waren in alarmbereitschaft wegen
diesen tag sie bemerkten dass personen darüber
sprachen waffen mitzubringen viele posten fotos
eigener waffen an schrieben den bringe ich mit
nach washington die algorithmische verstärkung
von emotionen dna von facebook stimmen die eine
abkehr von diesem modell sagte bergs fordern
würden ignoriert fünf jahre recherche rund 400
interviews die meisten davon mit mitarbeiter innen
das buch liegt den seelenzustand des unternehmens
offen es war fast so als ob wir in einer therapie
mit ihnen saßen in der sie sich jahrelange
frustration und angst von der seele redet
mark zuckerberg arbeitet derzeit an seiner
nächsten vision dem sogenannten meta war's
eine art digitale parallelwelt
es ist der ultimative traum der
werbeindustrie eine plattform auf
der user tag und nacht verbringen
facebook bestreitet dass das unternehmen
schlechte inhalte förderung der für die
außenkommunikation verantwortliche manager
nick clegg nennt die anschuldigung lächerlich
unsere aufgabe ist es das schlechte zu mildern
es zu reduzieren und das gute zu verstärken
und genau darum geht es bei unserer forschung
facebook erreicht mit seinen diversen angeboten
ein drittel der weltbevölkerung die macht des
unternehmens kann man kaum überschätzen ob sich
etwas ändert wird am ende von denen abhängen die
facebooks gewinn mehreren den investoren und den
werbekunden in der deutschen politik heute
ein zwischen tag der herbstlich unschuldig
daherkommt in berlin an dem wir ihnen diverse
außenaufnahmen von gebäuden zeigen weil hinter
verschlossenen türen an einer regierung für dieses
land gebastelt wird aber die bastler sich nicht in
die karten gucken lassen wollen aus fernseh
sicht ist es auch ein tag der verzweifelten
bilder was sicher festzuhalten ist ist der
zeitplan der treffen gestern rot gelb rot
grün und schwarz gelb morgen schwarz grün fest
steht auch dass theo koll die situation vor und
hinter den kulissen für uns beobachtet guten abend
theorie stehen wir denn aktuell lässt sich schon
eine richtung ablesen ja wir stehen einerseits
vor den türen wie eben gezeigt und auch auf
eine gewisse art um einen politischen poker tisch
herum wo die spieler ja unterschiedlicher war vor
allem verdeckte blätter in der hand halten
wobei armin laschet ja offensichtlich noch
online spielen kann also für ihn gibt es nur
noch sieg- oder alles weg dass laschet lager
hofft jetzt dass er morgen im gespräch mit den
grünen seine spiel künste zeigen könne also als
verhandlungsführer der auch den anderen stiche
und erfolge zugesteht und da habe ich am ende
dann selbst gewinnt die grünen wiederum wollen
morgen die handlungsfähigkeit der union ausloten
also wieviel prokura hat armin laschet eigentlich
noch nach der ganzen innerparteilichen kritik also
kann er wesentliche zugeständnisse machen und
dann auch in der union durchsetzen das war ja
das erfolgsgeheimnis bei den jamaika behandlung
in schleswig holstein und ohne diese politische
prokura so hört man bei den grünen wird es nicht
gehen kann es dann sein theo dass ab morgen
die variante mit der union dann auch bereits
geschichte ist nämlich wenn es bei den grünen
wirklich probleme gibt oder mit den grünen viel
mehr also möglich ist in diesen tagen natürlich
alles so dass beispielsweise aus dem gespräch der
union mit der fdp offensichtlich vertrauliches
durchgestochen worden an die bild zeitung und
prompt kommentierte dann ein fdp verhandler das
feld auf liebe union und es nervt da auch aus
den unions vorgesprächen berichtet wurde ist es
also nicht ganz abwegig davon auszugehen dass
die quelle jemand aus der union war und genau
so nahe liegen könnte sein dass dieser jemand
laschet durch die indiskretion schaden wollte
beziehungsweise seine verhandlungs schwächung
in kauf genommen hat nach dem morgigen gespräch
wollen grüne und fdp dann jeweils parteiintern die
erste runde der gespräche bewerten und dann ihre
ergebnisse miteinander vergleichen und danach
gibt es dann entweder weitere vorgespräche oder
schon eine entscheidung über die richtung der
dann drei sondierungen ich gehe mal von außen
sonst morgen wieder sehen und hören werden theo
vielen dank für heute und auch unsere nächste
geschichte heute abend spielt in bereichen
deren dimensionen wir uns kaum vorstellen
können die größte eigentlich vertrauliche daten
sammlung die einem internationalen netzwerk von
investigativ journalisten je zugespielt wurde
die pandora papers und ihre folgen hunderte
regierungsvertreter amtsträger oligarchen
prominente aus aller welt sollen geld in
steueroasen versteckt haben britta hilpert jetzt
über einen regierungschef direkt in unserer
nachbarschaft der jetzt besonders ins visier gerät
andré barisch im pool seine frau in ihrem garten
bürgernah trotz reichtum wollte der tschechische
ministerpräsident wirken mit social media post
von seinem französischen anwesen nun zeigt sie
ein investigativ netzwerk als beleg für ein
fragwürdiges geschäft diese und weitere immobilien
kaufte der tschechische ministerpräsident für 15
millionen euro über briefkastenfirmen mit shine
krediten schwer nachvollziehbare geldflüsse unklar
ist ob und wie illegal das war klar ist fünf
tage vor parlamentswahlen bringt das barbisch in
erklärungsnot ich besitze nichts an frankreich
ich habe keine briefkastenfirma sagt er und
beteuert dann das maklerbüro empfahl den kauf über
anwälte abzuwickeln da gibt's nichts illegales
gleichzeitig opfer und gesetzestreuer bürger so
geben sich nun viele bekannte persönlichkeiten
mit macht und geld der britische ex premier blair
der ukrainische staatspräsident zia lenski der
jordanische könig abdullah und noch nicht sie sind
in erklärungsnot denn auch wenn verschleiern an
sich nicht illegal ist so stellt sich doch eine
frage warum nutzt man diese sehr komplizierten
strukturen die dort stattfinden und dafür kann es
ja auch durchaus legale nachvollziehbare gründe
geben aber gerade seine anonymität gerade
so eine versteckte situation hilft natürlich
auch möglichen geldfälschern und organisierte
kriminalität versteck zu bleiben für politiker
gelten in tschechien strengere regeln habe ich
hätte den besitz offenlegen müssen das verlangt
das gesetz die polizei prüft nun die vorwürfe
sie tut das bei barbisch nicht zum ersten mal
denn für sein hotel storchennest bekam barbisch zu
unrecht eu-geld die polizei empfiehlt seit monaten
einer anklage der neuerliche skandal könnte den
wahlausgang verändern seine stammwähler werden
sich nicht irritieren lassen aber gleichzeitig
ist es für andere vielleicht eine skandal zu viel
das könnte alles ändern zugunsten der opposition
weiter 14 uhr öffnen die wahllokale bis dahin
ist tschechien eine politische schlammschlacht
garantiert wahrscheinlich sogar darüber hinaus
denn keine partei wird die absolute mehrheit
erringen trotz der skandale hat babbel chancen
regierungschef zu bleiben so und jetzt hier einen
erster nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag 11 da
bleiben wir beim thema geld die rechnungshöfe von
bund und ländern dringen auf ein beibehalten der
schuldenbremse auf ihrer herbstkonferenz arbeiten
sie an einer erklärung in der sie eine nachhaltige
finanzpolitik fordern wollen die berliner
gastgeberin klingeln sprach vor dem treffen von
einer enormen staatsverschuldung deshalb müsse man
selbst bei investitionen prioritäten setzen die
schuldenbremse dürfte auch bei den anstehenden
koalitionsverhandlungen eine wichtige rolle
spielen ab heute lockern auch berlin und bayern
die korona regeln an schulen in der hauptstadt
den fällt die masten pflicht im unterricht bis
zur sechsten klasse in bayern komplett fachleute
bewerten das unterschiedlich die einen halten die
aufhebung für überfällig die anderen für verfrüht
laut dem robert-koch-institut sind 35 prozent
der 12 bis 17 jährigen vollständig geimpft dem
quote bei der gesamten bevölkerung liegt bei
64 7 prozent für unter 12-jährige wurde noch
kein impfstoff zugelassen seit heute empfiehlt
die europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema eine so
genannte booster impfung also eine dritte spritze
zur auffrischung dafür komme der korona impfstoff
von beyond eckpfeiler in betracht mindestens sechs
monate nach der zweiten dosis in deutschland hatte
die ständige impfkommission die auffrischung
bereits empfohlen für menschen mit schwacher
immunabwehr japan hat einen neuen regierungschef
das parlament wählte den früheren außenminister
kissinger zum premierminister der 64 jährige
kündigte ein milliardenschweres aktionsprogramm
an und zog die anstehenden neuwahlen auf den 31
oktober vor über geschieht das erfolg dürfte auch
seine corona politik entscheiden denn schlechtes
krisenmanagement war ein rücktrittsgrund seines
vorgängers sogar der nobelpreis für medizin geht
in diesem jahr in die usa an die molekularbiologen
david julius und adam katapultieren das
stockholmer karolinska institut ehrt sie für
ihre erklärung was genau in zellen geschieht damit
menschen wärme und berührung fühlen dieses wissen
werde genutzt um neue behandlungsmöglichkeiten
zu entwickeln unter anderem gegen chronische
schmerzen einen ausführlichen bericht über ihre
forschung sehen sie im heute-journal update um
0 uhr 15 der stolz der deutschen marine das
segelschulschiff gorch fock ein symbolbild
das die letzten jahre ganz gut zusammenfasst die
bundesverteidigungsministerium spricht heute von
sehr schweren stunden tatsächlich gab es wohl
eher lange momente in denen unklar war ob die
gorch fock überhaupt jemals wieder unterwegs
sein würde auf den weltmeeren zehn millionen
euro waren mal vereinbart um das schiff flott
zu machen am ende sind es 135 millionen geworden
und ein fall für die justiz aber jetzt ist sie
zurück im heimathafen kiel hebestreit berichtet
auf der gorch fock kommentiert kapitän nils brandt
persönlich das anlegemanöver des generalüberholten
schulschiffes der deutschen marine mit dem
heck voran geht es zum liegeplatz im kieler
marinehafen 2232 tagen abwesenheit sind crew und
kommen dann froh ihr schiff nach hause gebracht
zu haben war wieder schön hier nach kiel zurück
zu kommen und damit letztendlich auch in unseren
angestammten liegeplatz der sind seit freitag
ohne unseren namen trägt da zu sein und einfach
wieder zeugen stück normalität zurückkehren
zu können sie schießen salut meiner einfahrt
in den hafen wohl auch aus erleichterung und
selbst in der marine viele bezweifelt hatten
dass die gorch fock noch mal schwimmen würde
jetzt ist sie wieder da und damit nimmt eine
zeit voller pleiten pech und pannen doch noch ein
glückliches ende 2015 waren bei reparaturarbeiten
im dock schwere schäden festgestellt worden die
kosten explodierten eine werft machte pleite
staatsanwälte ermitteln auch wegen korruption nach
für seine kuh bekommen ein brand in hand ins feuer
wenn es um irgendwelche korruptionsaffären
geht auf der gorch fock denn es ist falsch
gewesen es war ungleich folgt vielleicht aber
meine besatzung und nicht hatten damit leider
nichts zu tun oder gott sei dank nichts zu tun
der versprecher zeigt wie angefasst brand ist er
selbst auf beförderungen verzichtet hat um während
der sechsjährigen werft zeit am schiff zu bleiben
außerdem glaube ich wäre es ein schlechter
zeitpunkt gewesen vor 23 jahren das schiff
zu verlassen die besatzung im stich zu lassen
und das war auch ein wesentlicher grund warum
ich gesagt ich bleibe und so ist die gorch fock
jetzt von grund auf erneuert was die steuerzahler
fast das 14fache der veranschlagten zehn millionen
euro kostet außerdem ist auch der laufende betrieb
die gorch fock wird auch in zukunft millionen
weiterhin kosten ob das wirklich auch notwendig
ist das muss die marine beantworten sagte sie
falls das dieses projekt völlig aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist trotzdem hält die marine ein
schulschiff für das teambuilding zur see
für unerlässlich und hoch im norden sind die
menschen vor allem pro die gorch fock wieder
zu sehen ich freue mich dass sie wieder da ist
obwohl ich finde die kosten sind zu hoch geworden
natürlich spielt geld eine rolle aber das können
wir anfangen mit berliner flughafen stuttgart 21
11 wo wollen wir da anfangen wo aufhören auch
ein vorwurf von umweltschützern auf dem schiff
sei illegal geschlagenes teak holz verwendet
worden beschäftigt die justiz davon unbeeindruckt
laufen die vorbereitungen für den ersten
ausbildungsjahr rund um die kanaren wohl die
letzte fahrt unter dem kommando von kapitän bleibt
unser nächstes thema klimaneutraler treibstoff für
ihre flugzeuge alleine wird das klimaproblem der
airlines nicht lösen aber es wäre ein schritt in
die richtige richtung und seit heute kann man den
konjunktiv wäre dabei weglassen denn die weltweit
erste produktionsanlage für nachhaltiges kerosin
ist an den start gegangen im nördlichen emsland
wollen sie flugreisen klimafreundlicher machen
wie viel zukunft darin liegt muss man niemandem
sagen gleichzeitig zeigt das projekt aber auch
wie viele herausforderungen noch zu meistern
sind und wie viele neue probleme entstehen
elisabeth schmid und fabian köhler bericht
unscheinbar kaum größer als ein paar container
durch diese anlage mitten im emsland könnte den
luftverkehr klimaneutraler werden lassen sie
produziert co2 neutrales synthetisches rohöl
als basis für kerosin bislang sei das weltweit
einmalig so der betreiber entsprechend groß das
interesse und die hoffnung die hier an allen
ecken spürbar ist es geht um die zukunft des
luftverkehrs auch dass fliegen muss klimaneutral
werden und diese anlage zeigt jetzt wie das
funktionieren kann hier wird kerosin mit hilfe
erneuerbarer energien hergestellt und das ist der
weg den wir in zukunft brauchen doch es ist nicht
die politik sind nicht die großen energiekonzerne
die den traum vom grünen fliegen vorantreiben es
ist eine private klimaschutzorganisation die das
fliegen aus eigenem antrieb finanziert durch
spenden verändern will und sie wollen auch
zeigen dass deutschland zeichen setzen kann wenn
man im ausland mit der luftfahrt oder auch mit
anderen personen über dieses thema spricht dann
schauen ja oft verständnislos an wissen gar nicht
wo man spricht von daher ist das glaube ich schon
jetzt gerade wenn das weltweit berichtet wird so
ein startpunkt wo wahrscheinlich auch ingenieure
in anderen ländern anfangen zu sagen hoch damit
vielleicht was verpasst die anlage produziert
das synthetische kerosin aus wasser und co2
das co2 kommt zum einen aus einer biogasanlage
die lebensmittelreste verwertet und zum anderen
einfach aus der umgebungsluft insgesamt wird so
viel co2 im produktionsprozess gebunden wie später
vom flugzeug wieder ausgestoßen wird der für die
herstellung benötigte strom kommt aus windkraft
deswegen geht dieses kerosin als klimaneutral
was wir hier heute sehen ist ein erster wichtiger
schritt aber bis zur klimaneutralität ist das
noch ein weiter weg brauchen viel viel mehr
und auch größere anlagen wie wir sie heute hier
sehen aber daran arbeiten wir schon so reicht die
jahresmenge hier gerade einmal für einen flug von
frankfurt nach singapur deutschland schreibt eine
beimischung des biokraftstoffes ab 20 26 per
gesetz vor der markt braucht das grüne kerosin
und so kommt bewegung in die luftfahrtbranche
deswegen haben wir uns jetzt auch vorgenommen 2050
42 neutral zu sein aber 2030 schon die hälfte der
emissionen einzusparen und dazu müssen wir einfach
direkt anfangen noch kostet der liter grünes
kerosin rund fünf euro mit steigender produktion
wird der preis fallen und für die flugbranche
bezahlbar fliegen würde grüner so wir bleiben
beim sprit aber zurück auf der erde nun bei
einer situation die aus der entfernung betrachtet
zunehmend absurd wirkt kaiser es geht um die
versorgungskrise in großbritannien dort helfen
seit heute rund 200 soldaten bei der treibstoff
auslieferung vor allem im großraum london und in
südengland haben viele tankstellen kein benzin
mehr hintergrund der krise ist ein eklatanter
mangel an lkw fahrern der sich auch auf andere
güter auswirkt hamsterkäufe haben das problem
verstärkt in der ostsee pipeline nord stream 2
fließt seit heute das erste gas einer der beiden
stränge wird schrittweise befüllt um notwendige
tests durchzuführen wann der eigentliche transport
beginnt ist noch unklar durch die pipeline sollen
die russischen gaslieferungen nach deutschland
verdoppelt werden sie ist umstritten weil moskau
die leitung für geopolitische zwecke missbrauchen
könnte eva grant dieser vollmundige name dürfte
in diesen tagen einigen wie hohn klingen denn
der chinesische immobilienkonzern hat so hohe
schulden dass die finanzwelt auf dem ganzen globus
hinschaut heute wurde sogar der handel mit ever
grant aktien ausgesetzt was steckt dahinter frank
bethmann in frankfurt es deutet sich ein deal an
hobson ein konkurrent will anteilig eine grand
tochter übernehmen und dafür gut fünf milliarden
dollar bezahlen beide konzerne haben sich bis zur
stunde noch nicht dazu geäußert doch selbst wenn
es dazu käme 5 milliarden dollar wäre nicht die
rettung sie würde nur zeit erkaufen es sind die
bilder einer krise halbfertige wohnkomplexe und
keiner weiß ob über gransee jäh zu ende bauen
wird ein angeschlagener gigant der superlative
kein anderes immobilien unternehmen weltweit hat
mehr schulden direkt und indirekt zählt man die
vielen zulieferer dazu gibt es an vier millionen
menschen arbeit und 1,4 millionen kunden haben in
immobilien investiert in die sie vielleicht nie
einziehen können wütende verzweifelte chinesen in
der evergreen zentrale proteste die das potenzial
haben den sozialen frieden zu gefährden peking in
der zwickmühle greift die staatsregierung nicht
ein drohen unruhen greift sie ein senden sie
ein falsches signal eva brand ist zu groß um
fallengelassen zu werden ein freifahrtschein
für weiteres unkontrolliertes wachstum der dax
geht in deckung verliert 120 punkte oder 0,8
prozent ebenso schwächer die wall street auch
dort dann am abend deutliche kursverluste sein
kern diverse frank an der kalifornischen küste
breitet sich ein ölteppich aus grund ist eine
undichte pipeline südlich von los angeles das
öl verseucht bereits 33 quadratkilometer wasser
und hat beliebte strände erreicht dort wurden auch
verschmierte tiere angespült viele von ihnen sind
verändert das leck konnte noch nicht vollständig
abgedichtet werden wie es entstand ist noch unklar
deutsch-russische zusammenarbeit deutsch-russische
romantik in dresden ist da gerade etwas besonderes
zu erleben vier jahre miteinander hat
deutsche und russische museumsleute zu
freunden gemacht einen kunst austausch
ermöglicht wie es ihnen so noch nie gab
und für alle interessierten eine schau nach
sachsen gebracht die brücken schlägt caspar
david friedrich und alexander iwanow
aus dresden berichtet steffen moritz
träume von freiheit für künstler ein ganz
besonderer antrieb ihre gedanken und gefühle
auszudrücken wenn es sich dabei um für
russische und deutsche künstler handelt
und um ein gemeinschaftsprojekt beider länder
bekommt diese ausstellung unweigerlich auch
eine politische dimension also halt eine
ausstellung in politisch zu komplizierten
zeiten kann vielleicht einen weg auch in die
zukunft weisen also einen weg wie man wieder
herausfinden kann aus dieser kompliziertheit
und verstrickt hat unsere beziehungen und das
zumindest die kultur der anderen seite oft gar
nicht so anders ist zeigt diese ausstellung
deutscher romantiker wie
caspar david friedrich und
ludwig richter mal in ihrer oft düsteren
und manchmal auch träumerischen bedanken
doch schaut man auf die bilder
der bei uns weitgehend unbekannten
russischen romantiker erkennt man die
gleichen sehnsüchte und fragen der zeit
was ist heimat was meine identität welche rolle
spielen politik und religion im leben europa war
nach der französischen revolution geprägt von
massiven einschränkungen der bürgerrechte die
träume von freiheit verflogen die freiheit der
landschaft die ja oft bei friedrich unbegrenzt
über die bild grenzen hinaus fortgesetzt
zu verstehen ist das ist eine utopie von
freiheit in einer zeit die auf politischem
und frei ist wo man oft auch gar nicht seine
politische anschauung erwähnen konnte allein schon
wegen des titels war sie im april als sie zuerst
in moskau gezeigt wurde ein publikumsrenner der
titel träume von freiheit war ein wunsch unseres
russischen kuratoren teams und es waren sehr
sehr viele junge menschen in der ausstellung
die in tiefem ernst dies als sehr existenziellen
kommentar zur eigenen zeit gelesen haben auch ein
wunsch von russischer seite stararchitekt
daniel libeskind der mit seiner gestaltung
die räume sprechen lässt enge und freiheit mit
einer art labyrinth erlebbar macht bis 6 es ist
eine erfahrung für die besucher die bilder nicht
nur im geschlossenen raum zu erleben sondern als
komplex aus identität nation heimat kindheit
alles dinge in denen wir uns wiederfinden
zumindest auf kultureller ebene habe man erkannt
dass es mehr gemeinsamkeiten als unterschiede gebe
und damit verabschieden uns für heute sagen
tschüss bis morgen und wünschen allen ein schild
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum wetter die
serie der tiefs reist noch nicht ab und auf dieses
tief hier im süden folgt schon das nächste aus
westlichen richtungen und bringt hier regen mit
sehen sie in blau ansonsten haben es immer noch
mit dem sehr umfangreichen hoch über russland zu
tun oder das blockiert weiterhin und auch in
den nächsten tagen schauen wir auf die nacht
und da wird es im süden regnen und auch nach
osten hin nach westen lockert teilweise auf
uns zeigen sich auch mal die sterne bei tiefsten
temperaturen von sechs grad in den mittelgebirgen
im westen deutschlands 9 grad an den alpen noch
am mildesten im ost mit zwölf grad ja und schon
morgen am vormittag nach süden hin viel regen
und auch nach osten das ganze verlagert sich
langsam nach nordosten in richtung rhein und ems
da gibt es viel sonnenschein zu nachmittag ändert
sich das aber da zieht es mit dem neuen tief zu
und es gibt neuen regen nach osten hin kann es
auch mal blitzen und donnern die höchsten
werte dort bis 22 grad am niederrhein 19
grad oder an denen alpen 12 grad alles was sie
hier in grünen sehen da gibt es viele wolken im
tagesverlauf da ist es also kühler die kommenden
tage am mittwoch ist es noch nass mit regen im
osten allerdings etwas aufgelockerter 10 bis 17
grad und ab donnerstag wird es trockener freitag
leichter temperaturanstieg aber insgesamt
wenig änderungen damit ein schöner abend